we were talking earlier about people
you've met and I know Steve that you got
to meet or kind of meet Elvis I did I've
told the story a million times so I
don't know if it's worthwhile well I
just love it so well I was it was 1971
MH and I was opening for an Margaret at
the Hilton in Las Vegas which is no
longer there for good
reason it's like they tore it down the
following day the worst Comedy Room it
like a ceiling that's like 80 ft High
yeah so laughs they the laughter Rose
above the audience's head about 2 feet
and stopped and stopped but anyway and
uh Elvis was opening the next weekend
and he knew an Margaret so um now it's
after the show and I know Elvis is going
to come back and say hello to an
Margaret and so I leave my dressing room
door open and uh and I did my ACT it's
1971 so the ACT is not fully formed you
know it's got a little you know
weirdness to it and so Elvis uh walked
by and he saw me and he stopped and he
said Son you have an oblique sense of
humor and then he came in uhhuh and now
we're talking I'm talking with them and
I know you don't know what to say and my
manager was there who knew all about Sun
Records so we could talk about that and
then there was a pause in the convers oh
first of all but this is the part I
loved Elvis has a guy
who uh comes up to to him to get him out
of conversation says Elvis I'm sorry we
have to go and in this case he comes
sorry we have to go and Elvis said it's
okay I've been blessed so then we're
talking then we run out of conversation
then he said want to see my guns Jesus
and we said sure and he was uh he wasn't
he was a gun he liked Artful guns like
an engraved thing and he was very very
cautious he they were loaded and so he
took out a six shooter and he opened up
and dumped all the the bullets in his
hand and before he handed me the gun to
look at it and I was looking at I'm
marveling at it then he took out another
gun did the same thing MH dumped out the
bullets handed it to me and then he
pulled out from his sock yeah a daringer
Jesus and then opened that up dumped out
the bullets handed it to me and then
I'm I'm holding three guns and he's
holding 16
bullets and I'm thinking where is
Elvis's guy
yeah to me out of this why won't he do
you remember what he was wearing yes all
white it was Elvis slim and he had the
all white and he wore that big Buckle
that the Hilton had given him to him for
you know biggest show ever in the
history of the world right but he was
very sweet and very nice yeah and that
comes cross when you that's a famous
face though Elvis Presley Jesus well
also the reason I wanted to because I
know that you met Frank cantra yes and
who's your absolute Idol but it was
obvious one of those situations where
you because I remember you told me this
once you were at a bar and it no it was
at George Slaughter's house oh George
Slaughter's house okay it was after a a
Sinatra Shirley mlan concert at the
Greek Theater and we all went back to
his house and Dinos shur was there she
was a big fan ofv oh great she's going
on about it and I'm thrilled to meet
dinosaur and she said hey do you want to
meet Frank I said sure sure and uh I
went up to him now this next part Paul
Schaefer maintains I've made up because
he said he didn't he didn't speak like
out of Guys and Dolls and I said well he
did though he said I said Mr s Martin sh
he said I know well of you and you're
marvelous that's I know well of you
can't leave that yeah I know well that's
not now he didn't anyway then then he
said uh would you like a drink and I
said sure he said what are you drinking
I said
anything you're drinking Frank and so he
turned to the barter and said Jack
Daniels and I don't didn't don't don't
drink Scotch so the bartender said
straight up we're on the rocks and I was
nervous I thought he said straight up or
relaxed and I said I'll have it relaxed
and he Frank said he said Straight Up or
On the Rocks i' known Frank 15 seconds
and I pissed him off he starts yeah Jill
beat the crap out of this guy are you a
so I good good Frank no it was
when you meet those people it is surreal
but you know I used to have that with
Mike Nichols and I knew him for 20 years
that I was still in awe like you talk
about Carson you're in awe of being in
their presence I had I mean this is
someone he both have met a billion times
but Lauren once asked me to go to a he
said you know would you like to go to a
Yankee game with me and I said yeah I'd
love to do that and it was a playoff
game on the Red Sox and so we're I get
in the car and he says um um we're
picking up I think he said we're picking
up a friend I didn't hear who he said we
were picking up but he puts you know so
I sat up front so there was room in the
back for Lauren and his friend I set up
with the driver and we start driving up
and then we start to slow down and
there's someone leaning against the lamp
poost in like a very cinematic way and
we slow down and it's Jack Nicholson wow
yeah jeez and Jack gets in the back seat
and he and Lauren goes you he's like how
you doing Lauren he's and he says this
is
Con he just very nice just said nice to
see you and I said oh so nice to see you
sir you know and then we're we drive we
see the game and my experience was if
you want to be
anonymous walk with Jack Nicholson
because I am my life is I'm 6'4 I have
this pastry on my head I am immediately
like me or dislike me everybody knows
it's me and I walk down the street and
everybody knows it's me and suddenly
nobody saw me because I'm walking 3 feet
behind Jack Nicholson absolutely but
then the real treat of the so we chatted
a little bit about a few things and but
didn't talk much he mostly spoke with
Lauren and then he drops me off at the
end of the night and I think well this
has been great and I get out of the car
first cuz I'm just going to walk we drop
Jack Nicholson off and he gets out of
the car and I just said it was a real
honor to meet you you know Jack and he
said my boy is crazy about
you and I said he said I'll never forget
he said my boy we're standing there and
Lauren's still in the car and he goes my
boy's crazy about you every morning it's
con and this and con and that it's
driving me
crazy I had no idea that even I had but
I just knew that I was an irritant in
his life and that made me very happy
very happy indeed um I'm just going back
a because I remembering this great joke
and I think it was uh Shey Green's joke
about Frank and it might have been Don
Rickles but I think it was shy green he
said he said and Frank's in the audience
he said Frank saved my life one night
you know this joke no he says Frank
saved my life one night I was in an
alley and I was getting beat up beat up
by some guys and Frank said that's
enough yeah that's
so and then there's the famous Rickles
joke which I'm story which I'm sure is
true which is Rickles asking Frank he's
like I'm meeting I'm dating this young
girl could you this young
woman it would really mean so much if
you just came through the lobby and and
walked through the restaurant and said
hello to me in front of her that would
really help me seal the deal and so
Frank Sinatra comes through and walks up
to Rickles and his date and says hey Don
I just want he went Frank please I'm
eating and Frank leaves the restaurant
and then about 30 seconds later two guys
come in and pick up Rickles carry him
out of the restaurant and dump him in
the
fountain is that last part true it was a
it was a fountain it was a fountain of
acid that's the part that's less funny
Frank had it constructed you they killed
Don Rickles yeah they did yeah he never
lived past